it is time for this week's pet project
amy lee joins us from the nspca and she
brought along someone who needs a safe
and caring home it's a dog named bowser
and look at that little guy what a cutie
tell us a little bit about him amy so
this so bowser is actually debuting to
tomorrow actually for adoption and if
you've been following along bowser's
journey has been really an incredible
one bowser came to us at 113 pounds this
dog could barely walk and he's been in
foster for the past six months
recovering and we've been treating him
and he's down to 70 pounds so he's
actually able to enjoy walks and
actually go upstairs now so we're really
excited for bowser to find a loving
permanent home of his own bowser looks
so chill right now so happy is that kind
of his demeanor
oh my gosh bowser is 10 years old he's a
beagle mix and he's so loving he's so
mellow he does have hypothyroidism so he
just takes a daily medication and
special diet but if you want a dog
that's just sweet that is really
affectionate that's so mellow and he
really kind of looks at you like you
know please love me and this is just
really how his demeanor is he's a
sweetheart he's friendly with
everybody easy looks so sweet how is he
with other animals is he a one pet uh
home or can he mix with other animals
he is when i say friendly bowser is
friendly i mean he you know he would
probably do best with just a mellow dog
just because of his age and his size but
he's friendly with everybody and really
just a home that that can give him the
special care that he needs ongoing which
is just that like i said the medication
and the diet but i mean really other
than that he just wants to be loved and
he deserves to be a permanent member of
somebody's family with his age is he's
not too
too active is he a daily walk kind of
guy a lot of playing or does he just
like to hang out at the house
you know he would benefit from walks
just to keep his weight down but he's
really like you know if you want to
netflix and chill with somebody like i
mean he's so sweet i mean
i can't get over it he's so so sweet and
just to see the transformation that he's
made over the past six months is is
incredible you're selling him to me i'm
looking at that little guy like oh my
goodness i could see him at my house
what a sweetheart so if you are
interested in adopting just the sweetest
boy bowser check that out you can go to
nevadaspca.org
or give them a call at 702-873-7722